how are you doing today sir how are you
we've done interviews for years haven't
we we have and it's it's funny you
mentioned that because i want to
specifically talk about one it was march
of 20 you will not remember it was march
of 2016
and i asked you about your interest in
coming back to do an obi-wan something
at the time i was thinking a movie it
was huge it got a tremendous amount of
traffic it got picked up everywhere and
you in the interview you literally told
me your idea for what ended up being the
obi-wan series it was like
literally in that interview you're like
this is you know anyway i want to know
how long have you been talking to
lucasfilm about making this
i don't know if we i i
that must have been before i was talking
to them because
once i started talking to them i wasn't
able to talk about it anymore so maybe
we didn't maybe we did our interview
just before
it came about because i was always asked
like you asked me you know
would you do him again would you play
him again and um
i started feeling like yeah i started
thinking that it might be a good idea
that there must be a great story between
revenge of the sith and a new hope but
that's interesting that we spoke about
that's so funny i think i remember
i think i remember maybe not our
interview but the sort of aftermath of
it you know
oh it was everywhere it was one of those
interviews where i was like oh this went
really well for both me and the
possibility of you coming back so it's
being billed as a six episode limited
series and i'm asking this question of
you as the executive producer if it is a
hit
people love it um is there a possibility
for more or is it sort of like we're
just going to do the six episodes
well at the moment we're just doing the
six episodes it was very much set up and
made to be
a limited series and and um
so that's how it stands at the moment
i'm listen if it does very well and
disney are excited about the possible
prospect of doing another one
uh
then i i'd loved i i loved i loved doing
it i loved play i loved working with
deborah chow i loved working with the
new technology
and i thought our scripts were really
good and i and i i feel like the
the experience of doing it with the crew
who were
you know so passionate about like so
many star wars fans in the crew of star
wars prod
um projects nowadays
that it makes the experience really
exciting and um
so i'd be totally up for doing more
but but but i can guarantee at the
moment it's just a standalone thing
of the six episodes do you have a
favorite
i have moments of yeah i've got some
favorite moments right so there's not
one full episode it's more like moments
yeah they're all really strong i mean
they're really strong i've seen them all
and i really like them all i think
i'm pretty blown away by deborah chow to
be honest i think she's i mean i knew
she was great from the mandalorian but
i mean you imagine tackling like
directing every episode of this and with
the weight of the
the weight of the fandom on your
shoulders you know
she's done an amazing job really an
amazing job and i i can't pick one
they're all
you know they're all they're all it's
like one the beautiful thing about it is
that we because we have deborah as our
director for all of them
just felt like we were shooting a movie
it didn't feel like we were shooting
if we'd had different directors for each
episode then it would have felt more
episodic and
because deb's
singular voice goes through them all it
did feel like just one long movie and
the episodes fall naturally within the
story but it is one driving narrative
from start to finish
so therefore there isn't really a
favorite uh
episode
sir i cannot wait to see this series and
i'm already out of time i can't believe
it um hopefully i can talk to you again
for this at another point yeah um maybe
i'll see you down the line yeah thank
you so much for your time and i'm so
happy you made this cheers man take care
you